[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we've got the fine brother
because you see Rhett and people out
there the fine brothers are interesting
people from the internet and interesting
people and we have an interesting
conversation with interesting people and
interesting most notably they're not
brothers that's the first headline don't
spoiler alert no actually they are
brothers we go to the deep end with the
fine brothers discussing growing up
Orthodox Jews in Brooklyn dealing with a
near-death experience on the Peter Pan
ride with an employee while an employee
at Disney World you can find out which
one of the fine brothers that was we
discussed their crucial role in the
formation of maker studios and why they
parted ways and what they're gonna do
when they finally settle down it will
happen one day going into the deep end I
think that's some terminology I'm going
to adopt as your biscuits continues well
let's let's go into the deep end and I
think the reason why Rhett is because of
my experience at the spa
now that I I've been looking for an
opportunity to share my experience while
on vacation with all of you not while I
wasn't on vacation with all of you I was
looking for an opportunity to share this
experience that I have with my wife with
all of you am I being clear here not
really you're gonna share some
experience you had with your wife with
all the people over the holidays I'm all
ears oh yeah as you know I decided to
have a getaway with Christy towards the
end after Christmas but before we came
back from North Carolina take three
nights go to Asheville you also went to
Asheville but we made a pact that we
would do different things and if we
happen to see each other we would not
speak to each other mother so it was
wife time yeah I think the point is is
that when you're in North Carolina
there's it's a great place but probably
the best place to visit and to get away
to in North Carolina is Asheville so we
didn't want one of us to pick Asheville
and the other one to pick
you know like benson and then be like oh
well you're a Nashville I'm in business
or let's both go to the place we want to
go
mewls invents let's not interact and we
did not interact however my wife did
send a text to your wife at one point to
tell her about a restaurant that you
guys should eat at and I know that you
did and it was great well that's a whole
other discussion here well I think we
should save that ok let's save that for
next week
that one restaurant experience about the
name of the restaurant yeah exactly so
let's say that anyway going the whole
terminology of going in the deep end you
know where's that because I went to a
spa the not just any spa the Grove Park
Inn and I think then we call it resort
now or spa that's what they call it
Grove Park Inn and Spa this is an old
hotel overlook in the mountains
overlooking Asheville but the spas
what's world-class but you got to stay
there in order to get entrance into this
place so I decided to splurge on this
and we would have some quality time at
the spa you know get a couples massage
there's a lot of guys who are averse and
when we went there into the lobby there
was a guy there who was not only averse
he was very nervous about the the fact
that he was gonna get a massage now I am
I'm just like giving the guy the poopoo
face yeah because and that's ridicul of
getting a massage it's just a very an
American thing sometimes unfortunately
to just be uncomfortable ok let me
emphasize my discomfort with coughing
how long are you gonna vomit he's making
us comfortable with like being touched
or going into a spa wearing a speedo
come on brothers I loosen up a little
bit I'm going on record
I love being touched period end of story
so I mean couples massage you're in the
same room with your wife but you each
have your own masseuse and they you know
they say do you want a man or a woman
masseuse I was like I don't care oh you
said you don't care that semester no I
said I want a woman ok but I thought it
don't I
if it was a man I'd be like ok whatever
but your wife also requested a woman
right
yes right so I requested a woman for
everybody did all the requests yeah but
before we even get into
massage I knew that this is type of
thing that you just go to the spa and
you stay there all day this place they
at first they separated us a man came
and took me into the men's locker room
had started giving me a tour through the
whole facility sudah grab your hand and
lead you well he he told me to strip
down and then put on a robe he did not
touch me and then I did that and then me
and the nervous guy he took us both
around and paraded us he toured us of
this place I mean there's like Brett
there's like 14 pools deferrals in this
spot about I've seen it on the Travel
Channel this pool here is 78 degrees it
is the lap pool as you can see the woman
there is not having any trouble floating
because it's infused with many minerals
to make her more buoyant really and then
this one has a touch of Tabasco sauce
when you're underwater when you put your
ears underwater you can hear music play
really and when you look up at the sky
especially after dark you can see the
simulated stars in the simulated sky
above the lap pool like doing the
backstroke looking at the fake stars and
this is almost like from ancient times
too right I mean like 100 years ago he
did ancient for America he didn't say
okay well it's an old place that's all I
know and then he said in this pool is 84
degrees and it's more for lounging and
then over here there's like waterfalls
falling into hot tubs then you go
outside and there's a there's a pool but
it is 104 degree hot tub now we're
getting to a good place like 104 degrees
oh yeah and you're outside and it's cold
and you can order a drink poolside and
then you go back in to the men's only
area and there's another hot tub but
then like a little round hole full of
water right beside it and I'm like so
toilet that's a small hot tub next to me
he said that's the plunge pool and I
remember this it's cold but this is what
yeah it's really cold yeah it's like
dipping yourself into a mountain stream
and then you go into the hottest of hot
tubs right next it might be a trout in
there and I'm
like so excited I get to do all this
stuff and it's just amazing and I don't
know why that wasn't mixed company that
was in the men's only area and I and
Chrissy said there was one in the
women's only area I don't know if I was
supposed to get naked before jumping in
cuz I don't I'm not taking off my shorts
before jumping in the Polar Plunge pool
I mean any guy knows that as long as you
get into the hot tub quickly things will
bright themselves pretty quickly well I
did it but I didn't I didn't strip down
before I did it then there was a sauna
and a steam room and all that stuff it I
mean this is even before getting the
massage this place is amazing now it's
expensive as all get-out but for one
full day it was like I was in h2o heaven
you spent like a literally a full day
yeah I got a morning until the evening
we left and got we ate lunch there
poolside but then we went we left and
eat dinner somewhere we came back
because I wanted to swim under those
stars yeah I can hear the music gotta do
that sometime I'm going full naked
though the and I'm not gonna be there
yeah the massage itself wasn't that
great but the massage it was great but
it wasn't any greater than some of the
massages that I've gotten out here in
Los Angeles but the massage facility was
pretty amazing I mean they were like
what type of music would you like me to
play would you'd like me to play Native
American or piano music about Native
American piano I said I wanted to mix
and then after I started halfway through
I started realizing that the piano music
was really cheesy and I was like eh
let's see I want to go full Native
America of course obviously that's what
you got to do okay I mean that's so I'm
saying you should go but I shouldn't be
there especially if you're not gonna go
when I look in there and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be naked alright but so I mean you
can hear it in my voice I'm revitalized
I have them for the few weeks ever since
I've been back yeah well this is a deep
end let's see how revitalizing this
conversation with the fine brothers is I
think it was pretty revitalizing as it
has already happened and now we're
telling you about if not just insightful
and like going into a cold mountain
spring of Internet experience okay you
know these guys Benny and Rafi fine
they're the creators
several successful YouTube series most
notably the react series kids react
teens react youtubers react these
feature people reacting real-time to
culturally relevant timely sometimes
shocking videos they are very very very
very popular yeah they've been featured
in nearly every worldwide publication
including New York Times Time magazine
variety Huffington Post and have won
Daytime Emmy streamys webbie's iaw TV
these guys are legit you know this why
else what why else would we not be
talking to them we would I don't even
understand what that question it was
that even a question I don't think it
was I think we should just get from the
questions to the conversation to the
deep end here it is our conversation
with Benny and Rafi fine okay so as
we've established you guys are if we
consider ourselves pretty busy but we
think you guys are the busiest guys on
youtube so quantify your busyness yeah
how are you know how your lives going I
mean like you know it's just this is
just another job for you coming in
you're having to do this podcast we want
you to just relax we've given you
bottles of water thank you nice cushion
I see it's a brand we want this to be
recreation on a relaxation for you we
might give you a massage we might give
you a mask whoa I actually want that
right now but nobody's gonna see that so
it's it's not happening right now
yes massage guys it's amazing we're all
naked we're naked each other massages
yeah I'm really good as happening but
innocent clarify but I'm not in the
sense of busyness I mean yeah like
currently we don't have lives quarter
full of people like to call lives we
don't have in the sense of our lives is
completely making the shows you know
when you meet wake up from your waking
life is devoted to producing the content
on your channels yes I am developing
things for the future wherever they
might end up being online or television
or film etc so there's no downtime like
you I mean do you eat meals do you
recreation
meals it's like one one day usually
really late at night
midnight which is not healthy oh you
know yeah as a matter of fact I follow
you guys on Instagram and I saw like a
12:30 that was me yeah last night cuz I
love to cook and don't have any time to
cook so I shot for the first time in
like more than a month recently and I'm
like oh I got a cook I got all this
stuff so I get home really late and then
I cook late at night I have a really
good time like a late night cookie I
realize I have all this food that I
don't have anyone to feed it to together
very easily yeah we finally took the
took the step when we were kids when we
were younger we never like even shared
the same room or anything it's only been
since we moved out here that we shared
the room we didn't live together for a
while we were still in film school and
then I was working at Disney World
yeah we were separated for many many
years and then ended up living together
out here and you guys even saw that
because we you oh you're one of the
early collaborators of ours but that
loss thing we did together so those
years ago and you came to that apartment
that was our same apartment all the way
until October yeah with the Abraham
Lincoln picture oh yeah no other decor
right I remember correct no beds we
didn't have beds you guys you guys moved
in and just started making videos and
you hung one Abraham that time period
every single video we made it Lincoln
was there we're gonna put him up yeah we
did have the rights to that thing though
sadly we really should figure out the
other thing I don't think I think it's I
think it's public domain okay oh yeah
he's been dead for Content IDs gonna
come after us for that like it so you
did move in two separate states yes yes
and that's the first life thing we've
done in like eight years is actually
move apart yes that's the like cuz
otherwise it always was like we have no
time we can't look for an apartment we
can't like actually think about what
that means and how we have to like
separate what we own and even though
we're barely home but yeah that was like
the first thing we're was like we have
to move on with our lives and it took us
like many many years to even do that
it's always just every waking moment is
dedicated to creating content and it's
funny because it wasn't like a decision
that we like made at a certain point
like a decade ago even though it's been
about a decade of this though it's
gotten a lot busier in the last like 18
months but it's still like somehow we're
just meshed like that and both of us
started becoming workaholics at some
point yeah
stopped right so workaholic as a
negative term I mean do you it seems
that you're kind of acknowledging that
that there's you've got to exercise a
some health for yourself step one is
moving out like living in separate
places in the sense of being able to
force the by every waking moment being
about the job I think even being around
each other yeah even though we're best
friends is also part of being best
friends and life is the work so by at
least having even a few hours separated
or when there is a moment where there's
like oh there might be a half a day it
isn't also then next to each other being
able to be like so what should we work
on rebel at least have a moment to think
well what else should I be thinking of
this is why we can't go on vacations
together this is why something you guys
don't do right this is what why when we
begin to think about what we're doing in
our free time our wives are like no you
guys can't be together because it'll
become a conversation about some idea
you guys are not only brothers you said
your best friends your collaborators
your co-producers on everything in the
same way we find ourselves the way that
we build our friendship is by working on
things so we have found that the
discipline of separation leads to us not
working as much yeah if we live together
if we didn't have wives and kids and you
know it would be very there'll be a big
temptation to just wake up and work and
then sleep a little bit here and there
so I can see that so you've kind of
forced yourself to make that decision
yeah is that helping well that's new but
it definitely is helping just just the
feelings of sometimes
oh I'm not working at the moment you
know even just that idea of like when I
get back home all I'm done if I make
myself not check email you know like
that throw the photo cross the room but
you still Instagram the meal that you
made it I don't really honestly and I
say this all I've said this before like
Instagram we were very late to the party
and I don't really like Instagram and I
don't like taking pictures and our whole
life even we don't have pictures and we
have some and we always regret like
childhood
why and we talked to her mom she's like
you hated it you would never let me do
it why don't we have pictures mom she's
like cuz you would cry
my three-year-old refuses to be in a
picture he's like Bigfoot he'll regret
it yeah that's the thing though though
is that we look back recently we came
across old video and our dad was a very
interesting person but at one point had
an institute where he was trying to help
a lot of runaway kids in New York and
made a video for his nonprofit that we
were in we were really really little
kids and we each have met little
memories about that shoot but we finally
saw the tape again recently and it's
crazy to see it's our childhood
encapsulated of what we were like as
kids which is not really what we're like
now but we're walking down the block in
Brooklyn I look miserable like I don't
want the camera on me I'm like don't
even look at me my life is hell
while he's handing a wide shot he's like
yeah like he's trying to say like we
would help right away kids it up like
just like oh my god Rafi shut up and now
I've had to be more subdued and I'm much
more up yeah overcompensating huh okay
so you mentioned Brooklyn and I think
some people might know this but we do
one in New York so that's where you were
born yeah I was born in Brooklyn
Hospital in a very black neighborhood
the family story is my older sister came
in and said I want the black one because
I was the only white baby there and I
look like neither I look like neither of
you you're the darkest of all of heads
true because you weren't black you've
got an older sister yeah yeah how much
older
she's almost three years older than me
we're all like two and a half years
apart each other okay I'm in the middle
middle of corner half years younger
weirdest of the bunch right yeah yeah
the middle child the neglected child
neither of you middle oh H I only and
younger mm-hmm yeah never an opportunity
to be the middle yeah well you make like
you're technically the oldest the middle
and the youngest which the middle of
you're the youngest and the oldest but
in the middle well that's called the
only child syndrome you're everything to
everyone everything and nothing
so what was it like you said that your
dad was an interesting guy what was what
were you bringing was interesting
because we grew up Orthodox Jews all the
way until we were teenagers or even
before that just quickly is that both of
our parents grew up on the west coast
and Jewish families
do you know Jewish history everything
nobody Orthodox they were big hippies
and our Father was like really into like
LSD and like lots of things are living
in the Haight in living in the Haight
1967 he was there you see Berkeley
during it oh wow and remembers none of
it or what he remembers tones of it he
used to have even our he's almost from
when he was concert posters that he then
sold some of them later but like really
classic post sold these posters on like
eBay for like five hundred dollars like
it's like those classic amazing artwork
posters that like so limited but they
got at those concerts but both of them
fully
you know like hippies everything
spiritual journey stuff then they
basically decided they went to Israel
and then they decided that they wanted
to become Orthodox Jews but in like a
hippie way like they were gonna go
undercover in the end where the docs
Orthodox - what yes completely I think
it was like the revival what was it like
it was underneath like Jewish revival
that was like a but
so our Father went undercover almost to
become a rabbi in like hardcore Brooklyn
you know going to become a rabbi there
without letting them know that that's
what he was really wanting to do so we
any no no letting the Orthodox community
know he was actually like a spiritual
because it's not simple process to like
not be an Orthodox Jew and then show up
and be like I'm gonna suddenly become
very very religious and they're very
skeptical of these things got it yeah
yeah outsiders that whole idea of even
like the Jews there is outsider
tendencies based on how religious you
are it's complicated
so we ended up kind of just getting born
right in that moment where they were
becoming Orthodox and they did end up
kind of embracing Orthodox lifestyle not
just trying to do it and get out and
become a rabbi and leave they ended up
kind of buying into it so long short
bori they were all in we were raised
very religious but things that they were
doing was very unorthodox where they
would be helping kids on the streets and
not just
the Jewish kids and not trying to make
the Jewish kids that had run away from
home for various reasons to become
Orthodox just to get them off the
streets which was controversial to not
make them be what they used to be and
there's a whole crazy crazy upbringing
that was like all walks of life would
all be hanging out and when we talk to
people now that we're still in touch
with that newest when we were kids they
describe it as it was just a place to go
to meet other nice cool people that were
trying to be good which is very
interesting with some of the stuff we do
now where we realize all where did the
idea for things like talking to people
and come from and we realized they were
embracing people while having opinions
and being a person it's like this
obviously came from being in that
environment where everyone was who we
didn't know the stories we were so young
but then finding out later this person
had this drug problem or this person had
this abuse in their life or etc etc but
they were all just people that were
friends to us growing up yeah so what
was it like being kids in that
environment where your parents had
experienced this you know transformation
but they were still trying they were you
know they were doing it in an unorthodox
way the same time we didn't know much of
the difference which i think is normal
when you're young like you just think
this is the way life is the only things
that we realized were different was when
we visit grandparents because no one
else in the family was Orthodox so like
we'd go and visit them and have to be
explained that they don't keep the
Sabbath they don't keep kosher you know
things like that
other than that though it was a pretty
great childhood up until you know the
point where you get older well it's
still great for me you write it up or
belly what yes but it's like you know
you get older and some of the rhetoric
comes in and there's and for me being
more of the I need to have answers and
let's have a real conversation and you
can't really have you kind of hit a
brick wall sometimes and what really
white ring kind of answers were you well
it was more of like kind of questioning
well why did we say that with one
technology change it doesn't say
anything like this in the Torah like you
know why do we say this is okay and not
this and the answer tor is like the
Bible yeah but not going into the super
specifics was kind of just getting brick
walls up because that's what it says and
we're not good enough now but then I
would go on and on about but the Talmud
the entire Talmud is just which is
complicated but it's it's it's a book
that is so many books it's not even of
laws it's about rabbis from centuries
ago debating the laws right and which is
something I actually still think is
pretty cool about the Jewish religion is
that there's so much study done about
arguing about why and I think that's
cool but in today's world they not a lot
really you can't
really ask while you can just look at
what other people thought and you can't
agree to disagree
you know you have to you have to follow
this way and I would be like but that's
contradictory and then the rabbi's would
just be like well it's has to be that's
what it says deal with it and if you
question too much you start getting in
trouble so so you started for me you
started requesting and getting in
trouble yes yes I start I went from like
the the person that was like the next
rabbi in my class to the one that was
getting in trouble often from asking too
many questions
okay so you got I mean you were kind of
this was part of your life and yeah and
you were kind of all in as a kid so but
then something changed so what age we
talking about like this school is very
specific stories of why it has it
started it started at age 13 my bar
mitzva where things get a lot more
responsibility comes on to you as a male
when you're 13 and or thoughts you know
you've got it you're a man now and that
there's certain things that are a cool
hat now you do the black hat is a cool
expensive but the way that prior works
becomes different than the school day
becomes a whole lot longer and like so
my school day which were already was
long the school day was 9:00 to 4:30 but
then it became 7:00 to 5:45 and then all
this homework and it was just getting a
little bit too much for me even just on
that side of things and so that's where
things started for me but also the 7:00
to 5:45 and there's still only two hours
of secular history it was three at that
point for me it was only to you it was
two and a half turn out but because that
the things that you have to learn in
America and then the rest of the day was
was Hebrew yeah a filler to be American
yeah but the quick story always that is
the moment I remember is my principal
who I was terrified of and he's still
the principal at the same school to this
day we should go I want to go talk to
him he's like well even seeing like your
guys I want to go back and talk to my
teachers yeah it'd be so crazy to go
back and talk to like Orthodox rabbis
that were our teachers back like you
were right but look what happened to me
now our teacher was hot and so there was
there was there was some interest on
that level that's why you guys yeah we
had some hot rabbis
tell you we'll have beers yeah the way
that it worked with the long school day
the 7:30 in the morning until 9:00 was
prayer that prayer was always at school
but then once you become 13 you're part
of something called a minyan which 10 13
or older teen or up males together can
pray properly there's things you can
only do with 10 males that are adults
and 13 is an adult in that world so you
have to start going to the minion really
early in the morning and do all that and
I wasn't feeling well one morning and
was like I I can't get up and do this I
need to sleep an extra hour but I didn't
I really wanted to go to school like I
had no interest in not going I wanted to
go and learn that day I was all excited
about it I was happening like I'm
feeling better let me go and I got in so
much trouble that morning because then
being told like if you don't come to the
minion you shouldn't even be here but
I'm tried to then go back something like
if this doesn't make sense I came here
to learn I wanted to learn it and that
was the moment that is very Parham out
of my mind I'd love to tell that parents
will be like if you had not done that to
me it is hypothetical I would not have
gone down the path of questioning as
much as I did to lead me completely not
to do this anymore and that's the moment
I can pin it all back to is where
everything's starting to change right it
crumbled apart from you there what was
the cold turkey moment was that there
was no cold turkey moment and that that
from there that was 13 and then we were
I was still very Orthodox all the way to
like 17 both of us did something like
non-kosher know my one of the big
moments of my life I was maybe 23 and
had a cheeseburger for the first time
when at that point I had had a little
bit of non kosher stuff already chicken
but like milk and meat together is such
a no-no and I it was a moment of like
I'm never going back I'm getting a
cheeseburger bacon cheeseburger that's
too far guy right where did you get the
cheeseburger it was at McDonald's
because the Donalds was such a place it
was like you could never eat there so
you know not kosher and it felt like
even though I knew it was like the look
of it in Ronald McDonald and everything
just kind of like Daltrey it felt like
idolatry it was a decade long journey to
get out for each verse of different ways
and then almost another five six years
after the ten years to really feel
comfortable with my decisions and not
have guilt and like all these things to
really feel like no this is Who I am
which in a lot of ways I'm very thankful
for because it has made me
look at the world differently it's maybe
not just accept things as they are it
also makes me understand religion which
means I understand people better because
I totally relate bracing even people
that are really religious I have no
issues with it because I totally know
what that's like and then it could be an
amazing a great thing I have a lot of
positive memories about it too yeah so
you moved out of the house when was the
cheeseburger moment that was that was in
Orlando Florida like I was eight nine
years ago okay so that was after you
were out of the house yes
you were down managing something in
business role in rough you were kind of
observing this as a younger brother yeah
and so what were you I was going through
your mind I was like I loved every I
couldn't I wasn't at the age yet where I
had to start like worrying or thinking
everything was still like fun and
everything was a game and I would get
stickers and that was all the learning I
was doing it was like oh sweet stamps
and like I'm getting I'm a great student
and like I'm enjoying myself so much and
then we ended up kind of down this path
where it was like Benny's not doing that
great in this environment we might have
to change some things and there are some
of that we're like also the Orthodox
community was getting kind of more
strict that we were in in Brooklyn so
our parents weren't even liking that as
in general because we were so unorthodox
in this Orthodox environment where our
parents even let us watch like beavis
and butt-head and that was like a
horrible thing like kids would come up
to us in school and ask us like what
happened I'll tell you don't worry and
so we were you know always trying to
start on the tradition of beavis and
butt-head crazy horrible things but and
we were playing role-playing games and
dragons dragons and we weren't worth the
doc's kids so it was interesting in that
way but it was for me everything was
just I was I was such a happy like fun
like I just nothing ever really fazed me
kid it was just always laughing always
smiling everything was great so I just
kind of saw what was going on and I was
just more fearful for him because there
was all this talk of like sending him
off to a boarding school and like he has
to go off to he achieve us somewhere
else because he's giving trouble and
like all this stuff and we ended up I
guess has a family to sign instead just
to move out of Brooklyn moved up to
upstate New York to a school that was
like not as Orthodox and to a whole
community that was not as Orthodox the
whole family moved yeah
my whole family they're not moving so he
went upstate and like you know it was I
still everything was kind of just fine
for me I have I lucked out the whole
experience for me was I got to watch
Benny literally like just get at my
parents all the time and like be the
horrible middle child that like was so
rebellious and then whenever I decided
to like also kind of be rebellious it
was much easier for me they're like
we've been here well write this story
easy for me is like the one the one time
only that I had the TV moment of like
I'm leaving the house I'm driving away
and I'm not telling my parents where I'm
going only happened once and it was
arguing over the fact that I started
dating a non-jewish girl I was I was I
just turned 18 and there's a huge to do
with my parents and I stormed out the
one and only time go to three years
later Ravi had all of high schools not
Michigan like I went you know it was
literally like I had my moments where I
literally had to like have the
conversations every step of the way it
was uh had to have the conversation I
didn't what cuz I when we first moved
out there I was still going to a yeshiva
to learn extra studies and that was
going on for a while and then public
school the only one of us that was in
public and they were still even then it
was like you still got to like keep
going with your studies because now
you're just gonna not even be learning
Hebrew and Torah and everything so you
still have to go after school to learn
that stuff and then slowly but surely I
had to start saying I don't want to do
that anymore
then I had to start saying I want to go
out on Shabbos on Saturdays you know I
want to be able to drive and do that I
want to be able to date a non Jewish
girl each of these were like mega like
intense conversations but not here
someone had said the way yes literally
with public school and I went to prom
and I played baseball for you know like
I was able to just do everything more
normal then my brother and sister
completely walked out I mean do you
think that I mean did your parents have
this sense that they were losing control
or was it like you know obviously it had
to be a different process for them
having come from the background they
came from and then sort of making it
really strict and then slowly coming out
any difference if somebody who's
Orthodox from birth if there was
something like that going on it would
not have been even though I say oh it
took ten years no that was more personal
journey than it was like strict pair
or family and that's the thing that I
know from having friends that are that
are in that generational orthodoxy for
hundreds of years have lost like you can
adjust so many family members to the
Holocaust like all this thing's it's so
yeah just leave it becomes an
excommunication scenario sometimes for
those families for us it was we have a
hippie parents so like it was they were
very open I couldn't talk to my rabbis
that we'd like to talk to my dad like I
could have those conversations with him
and he wasn't he was never hardline we
would have good conversations and it was
more for the things like deciding to
date a non-jewish girl or stop me make
my own personal decision that wasn't
like horrible arguments what's wrong
with you but it was more of like well
that's too much you know and that was I
think that was their own journey to of
realizing wait a second what do where
are we now and even now with all of us
like our dads still being the most
religious but all of us have Mel doubt
about this and I think is he still Arab
on well you never are not really a rabbi
you go through a pinnacle college and
you're still a rabbi because even though
things differently like a rabbi or a
priest there's no you can be a rabbi
without any congregation rabbi means
teacher so teachers all tend to be
rabbis and rabbis don't have
congregations but you can just be a
rabbi that doesn't have any of that and
it's just a teacher you don't have to be
at the head of a synagogue got a beer
okay
yeah so he's still a rabbi and people
still he gets called for advice for
things and still gets called when
there's a runaway because it was such
his line of work for so long now that
he's retired here and there he'll still
get called being like where do where do
I go to what do i do my kid ran away and
he's still like someone that through
that through the connections of people
he ends up still getting contacted about
that stuff you were to book about it
really yeah well okay I heard you
mention that you know there was a point
in which you were kind of in line to be
the next rabbi and then of course with
this rebellion and kind of seeing things
differently did that begin to change
your aspirations were you guys thinking
at the time we want to do something
creative like you were thinking I want
to be a youtuber I love that even that
because of people asking when did you
decide to go on new tumor-like we were
already making videos before you do that
so it wasn't a decision to go to using
online and I like a filmmaker but uh you
know even before all of that like I
wouldn't even necessarily was a baseball
announcer I loved I never loved baseball
you'd be playing in games you always
hear me announcing the baseball game
video games whenever I go to a Yankee
game I'd be announcing the game with a
little tape recorder like it's what I
really wanted
do wait you would go to a live
yes Major League Baseball still with the
tape record what are those little like
the bosons
that's called commentators oh you were
dictating the game well you're an acid
just like you know you watch on TV and I
was just going to a tape for you that's
that's what to do but with that I always
had my dad also had that little tape
recorder that you take notes for like
you know those little tiny cassette a
dictator fine but I started there and
even then and I was roping you into it
even back then I was constantly fiddling
around it was all started with audio
first where I'm like oh I wanted to make
little funny tapes and interview people
around the block or use this the speed
to make me sell make myself sound like a
chipmunk and like do stuff like that
that then evolved and all my bar mitzvah
money went to audio equipment and I had
all this professional audio equipment
and made hundreds of the talk show radio
shows as leader much it was every week I
would do a talk show slash Music
countdown of like my 20 favorite songs
whenever you would try to do bad they
become the po boy and you would
distribute it how to use it was in it I
would rope them in and play characters I
my such a character like I would like me
playing with different characters and
wrote neighbors in etc and then we would
play them because we would still be
driving from once we were upstate our
sister who was older would end up being
in school in the city so there was a
drive to the city over going to a ball
game this became family listening on the
two-hour drives the places good I mean
wow we made similar recordings but it
was just for own enjoyment we've never
never played the baby I got a tape ready
we're going on a trip I'll make it tape
for that it would be a big deal of what
became number one it was her family was
like oh wow that went to the
based on my wall like what the current
chart was excellent even before any
recordings and stuff the playtime and
everything of just of around the block
were always these like crazy imaginative
adventures that he would create for us
in our weather we had toys or no toys
and like we were big and like even when
we came to the Internet with this
three-hour-long GI Joe action figure
thing many years ago we that came from
what we used to do and play with GI Joes
but it wasn't the laboratory right it
wasn't crash into each other or fight
with guns it was like all right here's
the storyline for this episode of GI Joe
and destro just really pissed off you
know general hawk and like you know cuz
he just I was about to say slept with
his wife
so you know you just cause he was
jealous of his silver head oh definitely
it's crazy because we recently
reconnected with our we had one of our
good friends growing up was our Catholic
next-door neighbor just so random that
we had like a real our best friend was
our next-door neighbor who was more
religious than us and then our a
Catholic girl who was extremely
controversial rose to be hanging out
with Lisa both of them but even talking
to her when reminiscing about the past
she talked about specific and it's weird
for me hearing because I don't remember
it in the same way that he does and she
does of being like she even called out
what it was like and it was like we'd
get together and you would just tell us
what we were playing that day and we'd
like adventures we play ventures on the
block and I don't fully remember it that
way I was just all in our heads like you
know in the sense of like he would just
put I couldn't this is the magical
crayon that brings us to another place
so you are creative dictator which which
led into he never maker no originally
when the family got a video camera I
want to say it was maybe 12 or 13 and
that's when the sketches started and
they were very very small but that's
where that all began and it was roping
him in and roping neighbors and to start
making little commercials and little
things not nearly as good as your
commercials guys and that's where that
started and then it evolved into longer
content mostly with toys almost
everything we did in the beginning was
with toys that's what we had they're the
easiest to work right yeah all we had
was toys there was five different
30-minute to two hour-long
action figure things and then we would
show two
and like the screenings grew to like
like 50 people at best these not
stop-motion this is like yeah in the
beginning you could see our hands and
our bindings care about that beauty is
saying the line down in the beginning
and then they got better and better I
remember when GI Joe v came out where
and that would I already move at that
point you had your five I was already an
adult and in Florida and then showing it
to all of my Disney co-workers and they
were like this is pretty good it's like
edge of five we've gotten we've come a
long way add that turning it up in the
break room to come screening the many
Film Festival month let me ask you so
even now how does the dynamic play out
it because back then it sounds like you
were this creative visionary that you
are a willing participant that kind of
got pulled into this thing do you still
have kind of that role separation in
that way now are you pretty creative the
origination of ideas is fully together
yeah like we don't yet we never remember
who came up with the original idea of
something it's it always just comes out
of us just sitting and just starting to
talk and some other things to do still
to this day we try to set aside time
scheduled just to be creative and let's
talk about new ideas and I actually
really enjoy that more than anything
else and then the actual execution of
writing it it has always been Benny he
goes and he bait we call it he vomits it
out and like he'll he's been known
depending on what we're doing to
literally write like literally an
hour-and-a-half feature he'll write in
like two days he'll just like vomit and
just throw it out there and then usually
my job no matter even if it's a three
page script or a 90 page script or it's
a treatment or you know whatever it is
it's I then and the editor to basically
be like great we came up with all the
ideas great great great you go do it and
then I'll take it after the fact and
I'll shape it and mostly that ended up
happening when we got older because I
went to film school he didn't so the
idea of like how to put together a
screenplay in the proper way to even the
way we're gonna shoot it thinking about
the action thinking about how
everything's gonna go into that became
like he's the creative like mad genius
he's gonna vomit it all out and I'm
gonna help sculpt it and put it to what
we need to actually you get the
technology right which is how it all
started now as you now
so many years kind of ebb and flow and
like now though I did not go to film
school from doing this for all this time
now like I know all that stuff for the
most part but and I can assist in that
in ways I couldn't before
and same with him he was never really
the writer from being around it he was a
capable writer as well and it just kind
of as kind of more through but now as
we're growing and moving on we're not
pulling ourselves out of everything but
we're really liking we're wanting to be
more of the creative minds to then
pushed other people to write produce
more producers we're leaning towards a
more producing level because you can't
grow anything and show running in
executive to be high up because I'm sure
you guys dealing with it too you can't
you have so many ideas and you want to
execute them and you literally come to a
point where you're like this I literally
physically there's not enough hours in
the day where I need other people to
know the bottlenecks employee we don't
live together anymore so there's even
less did you go to broadcasting school
or now my my quick story on that I was
so from the really religious Jewish
school to moving upstate to the smaller
Jewish school did not work I was too
beyond it and I also was a very shy kid
and I went from a large class to a class
of three people in the middle of nowhere
town and I couldn't handle even that so
long story short when they didn't know
they were gonna send me away or not I
ended up homeschooling and then through
homeschooling ended up done with school
in terms of high school at 15 so I was
in a community college part-time at
fifteen and then stayed part-time or
full-time all the way to age 19 doing
great and hating my life like I never
liked institutionalized schooling and
that's when I ended up down at Walt
Disney World because there was the Walt
Disney World College Program which if
you're not familiar with it there's
thousands of them that they recruit from
around the country and around the world
now slaves slave wages to come be were
custom take a semester off and go work
at Walt Disney World
it used to be get credit and then the
schools got wise and realized it was
just indentured servitude and even get
credit anymore you're cleaning up vomit
some people I was I know you didn't but
some of them did they got college credit
for clear to go five years ago so that's
when I ended up down there to do that
the time that I never stand everyone
back task so from nineteen I went there
for the semester went back home to shoot
a feature and then it came back and then
stayed at Disney all the way until we
moved out here so I never finished
school even though I was there really
young and what I did is knee why'd you
pick that was the early dream of my life
was to be a Walt Disney Land cast member
that ended up becoming Disney World and
I think that also has to do with
entertainment and the idea of how it
made me feel as a kid in the sense of
even the escape that I was wanted to be
him in a mascot
see look you you just walked into the
stereotype of what everybody says when
you say you work at this okay then you
wanted to be snow white they call them
fur when you're in the costumes they're
you guys would have been four cos you're
older you guys are so tall
oh yeah birth to all guys to be goofy
you know that was the worst height I was
so generic as a height yes I'm really
short really short a really tall yeah or
look perfectly like somebody so I just
worked in riots lots and lots of rides
I'm a ride geek still I love every time
I'm in a theme park I'm looking at the
ride operating console and like I can
operate healer like any theme park you
go to he has to talk to you about it and
he's like oh I see that they don't have
that button it's like so like hipster
about it you have that in common
although link was apparently through the
stories of her the worst ride operator
ever in the history of ride operators on
the Santa Cruz Boardwalk well yeah I did
that for one summer I cleaned up pee I
cleaned up vomit and I got sent home one
day because my attitude was so poor
connection whoa I like I only spent like
a couple months at Disney like this
after graduating film school and I was
working in the industry in New York for
a little bit then I we we decided we
were gonna take one year in Florida I
can't handle any more and then we have
to move back to New York or out to LA
and so during that time I was like I
need a job very easy to get a job over
there literally I know everybody that
works there thanks to him there's gonna
be simple all of them like managers and
they're they're all like rising up in
the company so easy way to get a job I
couldn't last like more than a couple
months I just he's a hard times I can do
it and couldn't be a part of that it
like an environment it's just like
coming from like arts and like
everything to be like just the idea of
being so regimented and like a
responsibility like that you know if you
actually I worked as if you hated it you
know not work there yeah it was it was
awful is amazing I couldn't like there's
so much responsibility you're being paid
absolutely and you have so much
responsibility
people's lives are in your hand because
of how these rides work also literally
like having to be on task you really
need to be paying attention your job and
people treat you like right and like
you're supposed to smile on your face
and everything supposed to be great at
the same time the like I totally cuz I
was around all of his friends and I
totally they all have the pixie dust and
they're all like it's so beautiful and
it's amazing well they also all know
that it's not perfect and there's all
these problems but they all look at the
positive side of it and I just couldn't
help but always just be like I see that
there's beauty and I love going there
it's fun
I really enjoyed Disney but I to work
there to actually be one of those slaves
I could not do it I got not did you ever
see anybody like because I know people
have gotten like decapitated by Space
Mountain and stuff did you were there
for that I were you ever there for that
when I worked at in Fantasyland I had
was a middle manager in Fantasyland and
there was a really bad accident at the
Peter Pan ride and someone got really
really hurt over and I got old well he
was old but he as they left the ride
never landed they got off they're
supposed to say when you come at the
ends of the rides like welcome back from
Neverland like this but anyway he
there's a moving belt at the Peter Pan
like Haunted Mansion moving platform but
Peter Pan is very old ride in Florida
that has not ever been renovated in the
way that it has been in other theme
parks so the moving belt never has a
slow speed and most of it most of these
rides have slow speeds on the moving
belt not Peter Pan the only way to stop
it is to emergency stop it which you
don't want to do because it's hard to
load the ride back up and it might not
turn back on
so when guests with disabilities come on
you have to bring them up the back and
they have to step on the moving platform
and you train them as they get up there
man I probably introvert on this story
but uh that you you have them hey when
the boat comes across grab the back of
the boat and then step use it to balance
yourself and step onto the moving
platforms a disabled person its guess
with disability and feel that can't walk
but not very well right yeah okay so and
you tell otherwise Mickey will come back
here comes a boat exact grab hold at
Peter Pan's flight has a story where
they or a guest has tripped like there's
a million at all of us because it just
is not safe
but anyway so everyone trips this
particular guest trip
fell face-first into the track and then
the e stopped it but all when the e stop
happens all the boats like kind of swing
forward and the boats Wang right into
his neck so I got there - like Reservoir
Dogs blood and I thought he was dead but
he wasn't
but bad is too bad it was really bad
accident and then Captain Hook you guys
it was dark they gonna swoop in there
they airlifted him over the it's a small
world building which I thought was
pretty funny but yeah
two days later I had my next interview
for management and that accent had just
happened and so every all my different
interviews were like were you part of
the incident
and I was like I was the first responder
to the incident and I got promoted the
next week Billy did such a good job
ships - because it was Valentine's Day
when this happened and I even back then
always single had the one of the guys
like look I have a girlfriend I want to
switch you know can you work my night
shift and I'm like sure fine and I did
it and that happened and we both were up
for manager he didn't get it and I did
it so I always would tell him it's
because we were there it would have been
you because you would have dealt with
the Valentine's Day Massacre that day
every year on Valentine's Day we still
email each other and be like happy
Massacre day let's see if that
opportunistic approach to your job
applies to YouTube so you went you guys
moved to LA yeah from Florida yeah in
2007 you kind of deliver an ultimatum
that listen I got to get out of here and
you were both there at the time at
Disney World
well he finished film school yeah and
was doing working in the industry and
working his way up through camera
departments and stuff now where'd you go
to school
Hunter College which is a city School in
New York City okay and so when he was
doing that he was making his way I've
worked for Comedy Central shows and
different series and stuff and then the
decision was because we were still
making stuff together when we could
because we had already made feature
films I went to film festivals we had
like done stuff already even in like
high school but it kind of stopped
because of us separating and then he I
remember the conversation even if like
what what makes sense being like I can
keep doing this and I might be able to
move up and get maybe that working on
other
or do we say no like why are we gonna
keep working for other people we need to
just get back together it's been years
and let's just I'm making things
together again and go and we already
specifically for the year for the
internet correct and we were just like
we saw things like Homestar Runner and
channel 101 and we were just like we
just needed this 2005 this was well this
was 2003 when this conversation happened
because this was we had gone through the
film festival circuit in 2001 not the
big film festivals just even small ones
with our comp with our live r1
live-action feature and thought that was
the plan every year were gonna make a
feature we were influenced by Kevin
Smith and thought oh he made it we can
make it and we could do this they saw
right away impossible like two former
Orthodox Jews who know no one is never
gonna make in the film festival circuit
what do we do and the internet was a
decision we made in 2003 being like the
Internet we don't we didn't imagine it
was gonna be this but we thought that's
gonna be a way to get audience its kind
of way to show people when you have no
connections hey you can make something
I'm interested in how kids react came
about but let's go back to the whole
maker part of this because I remember it
the at the the founding moments of maker
you guys were a part of that or for
shortly afterward yeah we were not a
part of that original like when the
trailer came out and even the fish
station to station trailer and that core
group not to a punch yeah it's now now
what people know or not know is called
nacho punch ah but originally
youtube.com slash the station which
brings you to nacho pond correct was
that group the group of some really
elite top youtubers at that time which
at that time the biggest ones were
Philip DeFranco Shane Dawson and Hayes
and then other people were in there
lisanova shaycarl Kassem G hi I'm Ron
and one way today there is that all of
them totally sketch well totally sketch
but he was there he was my consideration
right he wasn't like the correct in the
trailer so they made a bunch of content
already got it off the ground and then
we were in the scenario where like we
always thought we would never be able to
become some bigger thing on YouTube we
would we always wanted to work for a
college humor we were like this is I
guess what we have but we needed to make
we had to make a living like
look for a job still has still flying
back to Orlando to still work every few
months is they let me stay on as a
seasonal manager so I would fly back
every few months he had a day job on the
belt
get back here if we need help but so we
went in there just kind of we wanted to
have just a conversation with the people
that were running the company because we
knew some of them and we knew Shane and
it was like well how can we maybe help
you guys can we maybe get a paycheck is
how it kind of started and from there
they kind of sold us on like you should
just be here yeah and within two months
we were the head of production and the
head of creative for maker studios and
hired the entire first staff and we're
producing or writing or combination for
all of those channels at from like
November oh 9 to July 2010 something
like that though very few people even
know we were ever there because the
whole point of it even for us was like
we're running it for everyone else it
was not about us it was about all of
them and building something that they
talked about in an idealistic way that
we believed in once things stopped
matching up with where the company was
going to what we believed in we left so
you were producing things that we would
know like you mentioned to me going deep
with kassimatis mg yeah yeah it would be
the station again natural punch they
recently they got rid of all the videos
you can't see them anymore so all this
work that we did over at the station is
no longer online so there was a whole
bunch of things that were on the station
that we were involved with and series
that never finished and things like that
but so there's all that series there and
then the we in the beginning of going
deep with cast mg we helped the book
that show and his awkward moments was
something we helped him with too and the
shaycarl channel like things like man
versus wife and the perfect life I don't
know if you remember those shows and we
were I think we actually wrote all the
perfect life episodes we wrote a bunch
of stuff for Shea we wrote more for Shea
than we wrote for other people either we
really liked writing for Shea but then
we would help produce and we brought
another writers we had a whole
contributing writing system for like all
the comedy clubs so a lot of the sketch
comedy that would show up on the station
was written by writers that - there's
writers on community now that wrote
things for maker that we had gotten in
connection with Matz even how we met
nice Peter that way - he was epic Lloyd
runs the west side comedy theater so we
wrote him yeah he told us yeah we had
him in here so they told us how
you and Lloyd kind of brought Peter I
really remember being on the phone with
him outside of makers like Motel lights
I we it wasn't called maker yet I don't
thank you but we were was it it was but
no one referred to it I was like outside
just making these calls because there's
no privacy we were all like bunched
together in these rooms said so I was
walking out calling each of the the
heads of these various places of the UCB
and Groundlings and everything and I
remember just getting on the phone with
Lloyd and he was just like I've got like
three people I want to send you and it's
too late waits in Scenario we saw a
couple of nice Peter videos and we're
like right like we have to bring this
guy yet so it was it was there was a lot
of fun I would say there was a lot of
positives in terms of the content that
was being made but what was the mismatch
what happened well there I think that
there were steps along the way of like
even when we around the time that we
first got there you know Shane and Phil
like had they're kind of falling out and
they ended up having their reasons and
if they're on here they could maybe talk
about their reasons but so well they
both been on here so now you have to
tell us there they didn't talk about it
well they had lots of other things to
talk about
well I we can't really talk about it
what are your reasons you know not
allowed to really talk about it but the
basic idea is that things did not align
like in the idea of us growing a company
and being a part of like the top of a
company being executives at a company
and also again if it really matches you
we're known better or worse is also
being very vocal people about
multi-channel networks in general right
and maker it was like the first one and
we were there when it first happened
when we all joined into one CMS account
we were I remember the day we all signed
the paperwork to do it like it's a very
big deal and from being around what that
meant and our beliefs in that system and
especially when you even see now it
wasn't just because of our history there
that we felt that way we have very
specific things about being taken
advantage of that we didn't want to see
happen in certain paper works for any
MCN and certain things like that started
not aligning with their where they were
trying to grow the company into this
gigantic mega thing that it is today
versus this thing that was really going
to be a United Artists supporting each
other growing to grow and promote people
and that was there was just a conflict
in terms of in a way it is like being
more of a business versus being a
business
but in a Content way and it didn't line
up that's that's that's a very s the
political way it's a political way and
like there's there's a lot of other
reasons and it just uh we couldn't work
there anymore but we would but at the
same time like on our side we couldn't
work there anymore but we wanted to
fully still support and help and be a
part of it however we could we just knew
that whatever we the idea originally was
like the fine brothers are done we're
now a part of another company you know
like just like if we were to have gone
and worked for a college team where
would it be about us anywhere would be
about College Humor so that that period
of eight or nine months was no more us
we're going to create more fine brothers
we're gonna help other people and then
we finally were just like with what we
believe in and the way that we want to
get there and how we want to treat
people and across the board we knew that
we had to go and do our own thing but be
supportive and help them how if they
wanted if they wanted it and they didn't
and everyone want it right when we left
working for the station and maker there
were opportunities other places a lot of
other people came knocking being like a
run our digital studio and we entertain
those for a bit thing knows that we want
to do and then realize well you know
we've never been full-time on YouTube
before and even being around something
like maker energizes you a little bit
when we're doing this for everyone else
they're like well we've never tried like
what would happen if we just developed
and just said let's take let's take six
months and let's see what happens and
that's what we decided to executives in
five years you know and it's led to a
brainstorm and I don't have the flash
card that I found when we moved that had
multiple things on it but one of it was
like kids reacting to something question
mark what it was on the note card other
shows that we leave like a Lindsay Lohan
making fun think there was something
called one week equals seven days that
we've never made ever done that you
never liked enough for us to make and
what is that it doesn't work I'm never
gonna win I think last moments was on
there what is what no-nos doing
it's it's the the the gist of it is that
the sketch is it'll start with like you
know Sunday and then you see little
vignettes that happened throughout an
entire week that tell a whole story
one week equals seven days okay so
you're able to quickly see in like a
minute or two minutes like this crazy or
somebody over there will start working
on that but perfect you'll see that it's
a brilliant idea
way to think of the biggest form so it
was part of a large slate of development
that we were in production for a couple
of months shooting a ton of different
things that yeah this was like a
shooting out of the experience of the
maker thing yeah we're like we are going
to rack our brains list a bunch of ideas
and then we're gonna produce a whole
bunch of before even before maker we we
had a system of how we shoot things
which was like there's no point you're
gonna if you have a show that you want
to make if you have a format you have to
be obviously to really test it isn't we
don't really think that piloting with
one Episode it really gives you a gauge
on YouTube pretty much we're like it's
it's a two-man team and you know you can
do everything with two people and this
is even what we brought to maker it's
like everything's gonna be two men
that's gonna be like a great like
director a camera person and then a
super PA and so that was pretty much
always kind of like our kind of version
of it and then you have to be able to
like shoot three in a day like whatever
that thing is gotta be three in a day so
we were doing that and we brought that
whole idea to maker for all the talent
and all their shows and whatever we
would be producing and so we went back
out of that being like great why don't
we basically just make like 10 of those
and like just go crazy and so that whole
time look we rebranded the channel it
was a new show every Sunday that was the
idea that sometimes was the same show
but like we'd have four different shows
running at a given time they would air
once a month right but you weren't just
thinking I think we talked about this a
little bit earlier but yeah you weren't
just thinking oh this is a funny idea
this would make a great viral video
which I think a lot of times is the trap
that we get caught in when we create
they always think viral series I mean I
think which I think it's it's so smart
you know for obvious reasons when
something catches in the mist oh we've
got the formula specially if you can do
shoot three in a day as a criteria
that's storming well we didn't make the
mistake of shooting for three days
that's not
and that's the other side of it of the
other reason why we really bought into
the bought into that concept and even at
maker it works really well was like if
you do that and find things you really
do like that you can shoot that much of
it frees you up to do the thing that
takes you three days to shoot one thing
and you're not panicked about when my
next video is coming out because already
shot all these other videos we would
have conversations with each of them
like we'd be like guys like the likeshe
or Casper or Timmy okay mom let me come
on Virginia anyways just like then I get
to yes you got it you got a you know you
got to do this then you have to this is
how you get your channel going you gotta
have it gotta be constant you gotta be
movie you can't have a week where you're
missing all that stuff like the whole
strategy of that idea that has become
synonymous with what YouTube is if
you're a big channel and then we were
like and they'd be like I don't you need
to make this thing we're like we're not
gonna make that thing until you make
once you have these nine episodes in the
can we'll make that big like you hold on
source and they towards it but anyway so
right so it was but even then the goal
of throwing things on the wall was
finding a format because we had the lost
parodies we had spoilers things that
were very popular but never stuck in the
way that we saw other things at the time
Epic Meal Time in a normal orange and
completely we were like whoa this is
working now we could we have to find
what that is what is our Annoying Orange
I think we like talking with Dane the
creator of Annoying Orange and
everything we were friends with him for
a really long time and we saw him go
through almost a similar process where
he was always making like weird little
viral series like funny really great
viral stuff what off eggs yeah like one
offs and series he would have all these
things like theme and face and like all
this stuff that he would do and he had
this base of like a good every video we
put out no doubt would get 50 to 100
thousand views and we were also in that
boat we were like 50 100,000 views and
you'd never really seen anything pop
more than that and you'd be like okay
who knows and they know listen put out
annoying orange and it was insanity and
so we were we started seeing that that
idea of like if we just find the show
because we have that similar kind of
thing we have this audience that will
then seed it to everybody if it hits and
we thought maybe it would be spoilers if
you didn't different way we thought
about that being weekly at one point but
then if you go back talk the around
October 2010 when kids react started
there was a narrative web series going
there was our Lindsay Lohan kind of
pop-culture parody thing there was
interactive content we were making the
last moments of relationship to the show
that
we still kind of do now they were all
just kind of going going going and even
right away when we shot kids react which
the the main the early origination of
the idea was that I was around kids for
various things we were shooting at maker
and I had to and I would if I was
directing or even if I was producing I
would try as you guys have worked with
kids a lot you gotta if you really need
them to perform you've got to become
friends with that kid before you start
rolling it's they're gonna shut down so
I started having a lot more detailed
conversations with children and it was
fascinating me I was like starting
trying to talk to him about things and
then realizing oh they're holding a
phone and like you know the whole
conversation was like this was not me
when I was a child
okay at all and I thought wasn't that
long ago and so it became from a
scripted place first and we were like
what's like some way we can show the
difference between children now and the
past and a script and then as we started
talking about that idea it shifted into
YouTube and YouTube videos and kids
watching and what would they think about
seeing this and like why are we doing
this we should just show them a video is
kind of how we got to it and it was we
weren't even sure like we brought in the
kids and we didn't know exactly I was
gonna be edited together we did young
yeah that we wanted to show them a bunch
of videos we didn't really know that it
was gonna be kind of like this
separation of watching in question time
I don't we knew we knew footage and
start we took the ideas of like well we
know we want to cover a lot of different
things in that first episode had like
double rainbow in it which was huge in a
really big video but then it also had
President Obama in a viral video because
even then we were playing around with
well what about kids talking about more
serious things like so it was like that
first two episodes of kids right there
you can see our mind at play after all
we tried these types of things yes does
it all work and we even then were like
we think the most interesting is
probably the President Obama like you
know and even to this day those more
bigger episodes are the ones that we
really get the most passionate about and
love that we have a format to talk about
things like bullying in a real way and
things like that but that's where it
really all came from and then right away
when he was editing it I remember
looking at a cut and I didn't know it
would be what it would be but I was like
this is going to be like this is gonna
this is a million views quick like I
know this is gonna travel around the web
because we had so many relationship for
so many websites by that point of years
of being featured on places so we were
just like everybody's gonna post this
thing like sometimes we'd be like have
we can only send this like 20 people
this one was like this is like much more
mainstream and more Universal than
anything we'd made before
one of the reasons we love talking to
you is I feel like we you know we were
constant trying to learn and you know
that because you guys are so active in
the way that you think and you're
students of the medium there's no
telling what you're gonna continue to
produce and you're gonna continue to
stay busy I think the question I've got
for you is when you know when you get to
that point where you're like okay I feel
like we can kind of take our foot off
the gas and I know it's tough to do and
I can relate to that yeah
what do you want to do when you settle
down what is settling down for the fine
brothers I think only like literally
when we moved was the first time we even
had a moment to start thinking about
that I mean I know for me I really want
to travel I definitely want to see more
of the world in the same way that I'm
getting to in a way I want to make
content there but there had to decide
it's like I want to I always have a and
it's just gotten more by doing these
react shows I love to meet people and I
love to see the way I like realizing how
how easy you can get stuck in your own
life and especially in America Americans
are very much this way we don't go
anywhere we haven't we feel like we're
the center of the universe versus going
to other countries and we're how do
people really live in these places what
is different human to human living
somewhere else versus living here I'd
really like to do more traveling and I
even looked so you guys we've talked
about this sometimes of like there's
envy even to the fact of you being able
to still produce the content that you do
at the quality you make it with families
because that is something we're why it's
something I really want ya know like we
both haven't gotten to the point we were
like we want families but it's just we
want being envious of people like you
guys and we have specifically you guys
have come up in that sense of like it's
a it's amazing to see that you guys have
been able to do what you've done and
have also this whole literally this
whole life
like like literally what quote-unquote
life is for people you've somehow been
able to do both and for me I've just
been I couldn't even imagine being able
to even I don't even know how I'm gonna
get to that point where I can't even
without ready to do that I said how bad
dude I got pregnant get a random baby
you guys did
right the first ones you can talk it
talked into it and everything J sexy
guys we we wish you the best in what
you're doing now and in those plans for
the future so we'll keep tabs on that
and it's time for you to sign the table
[Music]
all right there you have it our
conversation with Benny and Rafi fine I
mean these guys are defining digital
entertainment I mean it's it's it's an
honor to call them friends and it's it's
nice to have been able to really
understand their story and I mean I was
struck with the fact that they've really
paid their dues you know kids react is
by no means the first viral thing that
they ever created and even the things on
even before their channel they were
creating viral videos on MySpace well I
mean that's that's going way back I
think that you know there is a
perception from people who either you
know aren't involved in the YouTube
community don't know many people who are
who they see YouTube is a place where
accidents happen you know oh yeah the
guy who made that video and it
accidentally went viral and and while
that is a dynamic of YouTube when you
talk to somebody like the fine brothers
you're just struck with the systematic
approach the calculation is so
calculated is so tenacious and I know
that's something everybody has had in
common in one sense who's been on air
biscuits if they're also it's a nation's
but these guys are not just tenacious
they're smart and calculated and
purposeful and but we we luckily in fact
after they left we just talked to him
for a while
Bethany left you mean after we stopped
recording they were still here when we
lost yeah after yeah well I was on the
phone with him that's what I didn't say
yeah after we stopped recording we just
kept talking to him and asking them all
these questions we can't I mean you know
it's tough you wouldn't care about the
the minor details and nuances of
uploading and you know YouTube videos
seriously another hour maybe an hour and
a half of that and they could have kept
going that's the thing is I love when I
feel like I've tapped into something and
they just start talking completing each
other's sentences and just going and
going and going and going and these guys
are a wealth of knowledge
I mean they've they should write a book
you know what we should write a book
and get them to write it ghosts right
all right yeah that's what happens on
your biscuit that's what you get chomped
down go to the deep end I don't whatever
kind of euphemism you want to use if you
like being touched you're in the right
place we do it every week so I'm gonna I
Tunes SoundCloud stitcher you know I'm
gonna retract that just that's why
there's two of us I'm gonna retract that
if you like being touched you know
listen if you don't like be in touch if
you're skittish about that kind of thing
you're welcome here too because we're
not gonna touch you unless it's with
sound waves going into your ears exactly
what I meant
all right well see you or you'll hear us
next week
[Music]
[Music]